I'd like to thank the organizers for ask
you to help organize so um main interest
that I have to gut me into this field of
regulatory genomics is that I'm very
interested in how is it possible that
you take the same genome the same DNA
sequencing that these constellations of
these small regulatory sites are read
out to produce these very different
phenotypes of these are all human human
cells they all have the same genome
right in and make these very different
phenotypes so I want to understand how
does this work is on the level of a
system the kind of questions that I'm
interested in is if what is a cell type
anyway can we rigorously define what a
cell type really is and how is the
identity of such a cell type stabilized
given that we know that you know all the
processes evolved small molecules and
extremely noisy when you look at single
cells you start realizing how noisy
these things are so where is the
information okay how does the cell know
what type it's supposed to be in and
stay and what what are the what are the
things that matter and what are all the
details that we can ignore and it's as
you've noticed yesterday during the
discussion so as the amount of
high-throughput data has been increasing
and increasing exponentially or super
exponentially my sort of pessimism has
been growing super exponentially that we
were able to sort of answer these
questions that we're interested in so I
think you know we think that we know and
measure a lot about these systems but I
believe that there are orders of
magnitude more things that we don't know
about them and these high throughput
measurements are full of artifacts that
we very poorly understand in general and
and so I think we've been knowing near
the ability to answer these questions
that I'm actually interested in so then
the question for me is so what useful
things can i do if i want to be a
serious computational biologist and one
thing is well you could start a wet lap
and do something else
okay so that I actually did this five
years ago and so this slide is just a
plug for the first sort of major work is
coming out of our wet lab so justice was
in Eli's last year and so you should all
go read this paper i'm extremely excited
about this and I think we so we were
studying we were evolving synthetic
promoters in e.coli in the lab to study
how natural selection has acted on gene
expression noise in native promoters we
are very surprised to find that
synthetic promoters even if you don't
select them for noise properties or low
noise and that regulated promoters in
e.coli are all high noise and we came up
with some new insights in how actually
the propagation of noise from a
regulator to its targets is actually
beneficial in very general conditions
and you can think of that almost as a
rudimentary form of regulation right so
just something pushing on another thing
in a random way is often beneficial all
right and this allows you now to see a
very general mechanism how you can
evolve gene regulation de novo from a
statement on gene regulation all right
but this is not what I will talk about
today so the other thing that that we're
still trying to do in the context of
regulatory genomics is to develop very
simple robust and transparent methods
that can help experimentalist interpret
the data and guide the next experiments
that they're doing so that I think this
is sort of about as much as I think I
can contribute so one of the main sort
of systems that we've been working on
starting with this this phantom for
project now this is already what is it
six seven years ago is we developed a
system we call this motif activity
response analysis where we start by
predicting regulatory sites Gina why
didn't say all promoters for a very
large number of regulatory motifs or
hundreds of motifs in mammalian cells
and then we once we have these these
annotations so we end up with some big
matrix that gives you for every promoter
in the genome and each one of these
hundreds of regulatory motifs how many
binding sites other in this promoter for
this multi
and then we take either expression data
gene expression data or chips tech data
with you know chromatin state and
promoters and then we use a very simple
linear model that says the expression in
promoter p of in sample s of promoter p
is sum sum over all motifs the number of
binding sites in this promoter for this
motif time some unknown activity of this
motif in this sample and so we fit these
motif activities to to try and estimate
the expression now so this is an
extremely simple modeling you can say if
you assume that the deviation between
modeling and the experimental data is
Gaussian you can solve this all you know
without any problem exactly get the
entire posterior distribution and these
and you will see that you're able to
only capture a few percent of the
variance in the data so this is very
very simple in your models they do
terrible in fitting the gene expression
data which is maybe not surprising but
we found that they consistently do very
very well in identify what are the key
regulators in the system in the
regulatory interactions of initial right
so here to give you some one example if
you this is so this is just some data we
downloaded so these are time-course
measurements of human umbilical vein
endothelial cells that are treated with
tnf alpha and biologists know that if
you do this you three T cells with tnf
alpha you induce an innate immune
response if you just give this this time
course expression data to this motif
activity response analysis it up initio
identifies what are the key regulators
are nf-kappa B and I RF actors how it is
how their activity of these factors
changing in time even direct regulatory
interactions between these transcription
factors and what you know aspects of the
innate immune response what downstream
pathways are these different regulators
responsible for right so it should be
clear that innate immunity is very well
studied and this is why I'm showing it
to use an example because you can
confirm with the literature that these
things make sense right but for so for a
biologist that is interested in
understanding
regulation in his or her system and that
only happy sort of genome-wide gene
expression data it can be very useful to
get predictions of these kind that say
these are the key regulators these how
they're changing their activity time
these are the jeans they're targeting
because don't tell them what kind of
follow-up experiments to do perturb
these transcription factors and so on to
learn more so what we've been working on
for nearly five years since we first
developed this sort of approach is to
try and completely automate this right
so make this completely automated in and
robust and so we now have a website you
can go to this website and the only
thing you need to do is upload your raw
data and then click a button so there
are no parameters nothing you just you
just say go and then basically the
entire analysis is done and it gives you
sort of interactive HTML pages with the
result that tell you what are the key
regulators in the system what are the
activities of these regulators across
the input samples what are the target
genes and pathways that each of these
regulators target what are the
regulatory sites on the genomes to which
these regulators act and what are the
interactions between the regulator's
themselves well I think and and this has
been a very rewarding experience because
there are many many experimental labs
that have now gone to use this and don't
follow up experiments with these
predictions and find that it really
helps them to learn about what is sort
of how the regulation is acting in their
system all right so for this talk today
so this this program is also supposed to
be about algorithms and so on so I want
to tell you a little bit about work that
we've done for modeling transcription
factor binding specificity going beyond
the specific position specific weight
matrix is so number of people have
already talked about with HD cell
extract the ppw p.m. data we know that
that the position specific right matrix
models may not be sort of sufficient to
describe really the binding
specificities you see and so i will tell
you sort of about an approach that we
develop to try and look at this so just
to set this up i want to remind you that
when you when you infer position
specific weight matrix so the key kind
of quantity that you
calculate is that if I have some
alignment of short sequences capital s I
want to calculate what is the
probability of this set of sequences
deriving from some weight matrix W and
this probability can be written as a
product over all the columns in this
alignment right because the key
assumption of a weight matrix is that
these columns are independent and then
for each column you basically have the
product over all letters alpha and then
the weight matrix entries are the
probability of having letter alpha
position I to the power how many times
in I alpha did you see letter alpha
position eyes all right so this you can
calculate if you know the weight matrix
but the point is of course that you
typically don't know the weight matrix
so probability theory tells me if you
want to calculate the probability that
all these sequences s came from a common
weight matrix what you need to do is you
have to have a prior distribution of
possible weight matrices and then
integrate it out right so you calculate
its likelihood time to the prior
integrated over all possible right
medicine if you if you use it there is
lay prior I mean so there is sort of you
can wave your hands and have sort of
semi rigorous ways of justifying why you
need a prior of this type but so let's
just assume you use a prior of this time
then you can do these calculations
analytically and you get these answers
that have these gamma functions in it
right so for this if you look at one
weight matrix column here let's say call
them I the probability that these
derived from from a weight matrix is
basically given us a product over all
letters and then the gamma function of
how many times you see it Plus this
lambda which was this parameter of the
deutiche low price all right so now I
want to generalize this and look
generally at pairs of columns so instead
of it of looking at single columns at a
time we're going to look at pairs of
columns and so this goes back to a model
that was developed by this extremely
good PhD student that they used to have
called Lucas bulgur and we first use
this for for predicting interactions in
proteins and in contacts in in protein
structures
and so we have been adapting now this
model to describe transcription factor
binding specificity alright so the way
this works is that so previously we were
looking at these single columns at a
time right so this is column on column J
and is characterized by the counts of
how many times you see letter alpha this
column how many times you see letter
PETA it's now when I have a pair of
columns I have dinucleotide frequencies
right so these this is the number of
times that I see the combination alpha
beta at position IJ and now i can
calculate the probability for these
pairs of columns that just generalize is
what we did for a single column so
instead of having a you know position
specific weight matrix you have now a
sort of dinucleotides wait tensor that
is just the probabilities of all the
combinations of letters peering at this
column and when you integrate over this
it just works the same way it's just now
you have a little bit of size 16 letters
instead of four you again get these
expressions in terms of of gamma
functions and so now in particular what
you can calculate is a likelihood ratio
of highlight Lee's despairs of columns
under this sort of richer model of
dinucleotides relative to the product of
the probabilities of these columns on
the weight matrix model and you can show
actually if you do the Sterling
approximation of these gamma functions
you can show that this ratio is roughly
e to the number of total number of
observations in the column times the
mutual information all right so it is a
these discover functions they do the
finite size Corrections correctly but in
the limit of large counts this these are
functions is just e to the power of the
mutual information in the two columns
times the number of letters all right so
we use these things to now take an
alignment and write down the probability
of the entire alignment in terms of
these pairwise dependencies right so
when we did a weight matrix all the
columns are independent so the
probability of the entire alignment is
just a product of the probabilities of
the columns and now what we're going to
say is well we're going to draw some
tree that for each
decision in this alignment specifies one
position so for each position I
specifies position pie I that this
position is dependent on all right and
so if specifying this set of parent
positions were all nodes is equivalent
to giving a spanning tree of all the of
all the positions in this alignment and
once I give you such a spanning tree so
then that specifies a factorization
right so it says now the probability of
the alignment is the probability of the
first position so in this case this is
the root of the tree then the
probability of the second given the
first the probability is third given a
second so this fourth one in this three
also depends on the first position this
I present depends on the third position
and so on right so you get a product of
all these conditional tendencies if i
write thyself so notice that is so this
is the probability of the root column
and then the product of the overall
positions that are not the root and this
conditional probability is just the
joint probability of the two columns
divided by the probability of the parent
column but if i now also divided by the
marginal probability of this column I
just basically get these these are so
what it what it shows you this is once I
give you such a factorization i can
write this probability as the original
weight matrix probability because this
is the original weight makes probability
x a product over all edges in this tree
and then these these likelihood ratios
for each of the of them edges in the
tree now I don't know these three right
so I've assumed that I know what the
dependencies are in this previous slide
but I don't generally know this so
probability theory then tells me I have
to put a prior on the space of possible
trees so I will use a uniform prior
because I will assume I know nothing
about it and then I simply have to sum
over all these possible trees right so
to calculate probability and so what I
would have to calculate the service here
this is again the weight matrix parts
are we'd have to sum over all possible
trees pie and then for each three the
product over all edges in the two
e times these are factors these
dependency factors for each edge in the
tree so for example if I had only three
positions these would be the three
possible spanning trees and so this this
probability would be proportional to
this this sum here now the beauty is
that by a generalization of the kickoff
or matrix teeth three theorem you can
actually calculate this sum it's the
determinant of a matrix so what you do
is you take your matrix are you take the
laplacian of this matrix which
essentially means that you put minus the
sum of the rows of the columns on the
diagonal and if you don't take any minor
of this matrix so you remove a roll call
them and take the determinant that is
insect in fact exactly equal to this
song all right so the thing is we can
easily calculate this so we can
calculate the probability of the of of
any alignment under this general model
with paralyzed dependencies not knowing
which positions depending on which
summing over this by really calculating
a determinant of a matrix okay so once
you see that you can also see how you
can now use these kind of models to
predict binding sites so let's say that
I have this alignment of sites that i
know are binding sites for for a
transcription factor and i now want to
calculate the probability that this
sequence little s is a binding site for
the same transcription factor then
essentially what i just need to
calculate is the probability of little s
coming from the same model as the set
capital S which is just the probability
of this of the bigger set that includes
now lil s divided by the probability of
the set without little s and because i
just showed you i can calculate that
this is there now given by the ratio of
such determinants times a factor which
would be the previous weight matrix
vector right so if I would do it under
the weight matrix model this would be
the probability of the sequence little
as given the set capital s and now there
is this extra factor which is this ratio
of determinants of these are
dependencies that encodes the extra
evidence that is
all these dependencies between positions
so you can then also use this yes why
are you going through these trees at all
I mean why what do you think you need
the trees in the first place as opposed
to just with all the pairwise
dependencies as it did originally
because I still need to write down a
likelihood model for my data right I
need some way to say what is the
likelihood of this set of sequences on
this model and it contains all these
pairwise dependencies and so if I only
want to look at pairs it all the trees
are all the possibilities I have
right so the way this this the way this
works so when we do motif finding with
this thing is let's say you start with
you have a weight matrix and you start
with your weight matrix and you predict
sites for this weight matrix now you
take the alignment of this site and you
get these dinucleotide counts from your
alignment and you can do this by by
weighing each of these sites by the
posterior probability and then you can
do this the standard en thing because
you can now use these dinucleotide
counts to make your matrix R and once
you have your matrix are you can
calculate the probability for where
other sites are appearing and you
iterate this with in the in the in the
standard en way until it converges who
else has a question no no that compares
maybe my intuition to the maximum
entropy models that people will push
life-size we also have to get wise and
should look at this so you're okay so
yeah this is a really one of my hobby
horses but it takes a little bit long to
explain this so these maximum entropy
models they typically what they do is
they fit one set of parameters as
opposed to as opposed to integrating
over them okay so I guess that's the
main difference but they then give
themselves slightly bigger space of
models right so I have to go through
these trees to be able to do the
integrals they can do more general
random marker fields where I can no
longer do the integral okay and so the
question is are you overfitting when
you're fitting the things all right ok
so this in the in the protein contact
prediction thing this there's some
interesting so the developers have been
talking to these people of contrasting
these approaches and seeing what sort of
works better and I don't know you really
answer yet which of the approximations
is sort of weak weaker alright so we've
so you have to test this so we took a
large set of chipset data sets from n
called so we got binding peaks for all
these and we divide that about top
talent piece for each of these 83
different to scripture factors with the
validity to 500 train peaks in test
peaks and then basically what we did is
that we in parallel fit a weight matrix
model on this data on the training data
and fit our dwt model on this data right
and so for example afterwards you can
then look at the predicted distribution
of binding energies that each of these
binding Peaks have and then we needed to
calculate basically a score that says
which of these two is is is performing
better in explaining the chip sick data
so we spend a little bit of time of
thinking about what is actually a good
way of writing down a score for how well
does a particular motif explain a chip
sick data set and so what we did what we
came up with in the end it's a sort of
when idealize IP in vitro like IP
experiment where I'm imagining that you
have a pool of sequences that contains
all the binding peaks we observed plus a
very large number of sort of background
sequences and then you ask if I now
calculate how many with my motif how
many binding sites there are in each of
these sequences and I assume that the
probability that when I fish with IP one
sequence from my pot that the
probability is proportional to how many
copies of the transcription factor are
bound to this sequence then i can
calculate the probability of the data
which is the probability that i will
fish out all my binding peaks and only
my binding peaks and nothing else
alright so for for any individual
sequence s in this pot you can calculate
how many side-zip do i predict rns how
many sides are expected to be bound
divided by the total number of
transcription factors bound to all
sequences in the pot that's the
probability that if I now fish one with
IP data will that I will fish up
sequence s and then that the probability
of my data set is just a the product
over all sequences that I actually
observed in my set of peaks okay so this
is this score that we calculate and so
when we when we do this on these 80 some
transcription factors from encode so you
see these are the scores of the PWM
model this is of our dinucleotide weight
tensor model and you see that in
basically in none of the cases does this
dinucleotide way tends to do worse than
the PWM and many cases where it doesn't
make a lot of difference but there are
also quite some cases where it makes
quite a difference so here you see the
this is the log likelihood different /
binding peek across all these different
transcription factors and so I think
it's important to realize is that the
reason I think that we do not over fit
is because there are no tunable
parameters in this okay there's
basically zero tunable parameters
everything is rigorously
integrated out of the likelihood
functions you're not fitting anything
and so when there is no evidence in the
data that there are dependencies between
positions in the binding sites then you
also not predict any and basically your
dwt model will will reduce the weight
makes more is the model Donna two
different yes
so no that's correct you're right i have
to set but what i believe is the size of
the moment so yes
so
this one these to write the first to
register
you're asking me where is rap to anyone
okay so i would have to ask the student
maybe maybe maybe this data set was not
included in the set i have to double
check yes it's kind of interesting
because those three bind to almost the
same regions in the genome yeah but I
now I would like to come back to some
Harmon awesome nor was it Harmon has
made this thing that yeah I've been
amazed many times in that I can have pwm
models even that when I look at them by
I I cannot distinguish and when I go and
predict binding sites let's say in all
promoters genome-wide for these things
they come out quite different so
sometimes you know it's hard you know
you looked at these speaking segment is
pretty much the same sometimes it's hard
to really
they might be yes also like a map pain
and Aniyah happy tears
yeah this is rest right yes so I mean
yeah I have no comment to that I have
there what I mean whether this makes
sense it or a person from all right so I
just want to five minutes okay that's
great I can make a plug the other
project so this is project of fantastic
master student they said just blew me
out of the water really that so so
you've seemed like we do a lot with
predicting binding sites in the modeling
expression rating to in terms of these
binding sites so now that are all this
chipset datasets I thought well we
should start using these sort of
systematically to use them to get more
motifs four factors that we don't have
yet and maybe even use the chip stack
data to annotate where these things are
known to bind in certain tissues and put
it in our models and when we started
doing that i found out that sort of
chipset data analysis is Wild West so
there's almost no standardized
procedures sort of either even within
consortium like encode quite different
things are done on different data sets
if I found it impossible to use analyzed
data from other people and sort of
systematically compare them across many
transcription factors so eventually we
were sort of forced to develop our own
pipeline to systematically treat these
chips egg data sets in there in the same
way so this this is what we've done so
and and like with this is mara the multi
of activity response analysis we really
did our best to make is completely
automated something I have a web server
this is not yet published I'm putting
the paper on the archive as we speak but
you can't go to the website and already
use it so where you just upload your raw
data and the pipeline does everything
from the quality filtering checking if
there are any adapters left mapping the
reeds estimating the size of the
fragments doing all the peak calling and
then comprehensive regulatory motif
analysis and sort of i just sort of
focus on one or two things that are
novel about this so once
so when you do p calling so you first
use you you look for regions that are
enriched in chipset signal so you slide
some some window of a few hundred base
pairs across the genome and then in each
of these windows you compare how many
reads where there in the in the IP
sample with how many reads within the
background and you need some statistical
model to say whether this is
statistically enriched and so this is
something where I think we've take a
slightly different approach than a mouse
model cell already a long time ago when
I was analyzing cage data from from
rican we developed a model for the the
noise in next-generation reap sequence
coverage in in replicate samples
biological replicates samples indeed and
this molar basically has multiple
multiplicative noise followed by force
on sampling and you can show that you
can well approximate the this model as
follows so the what I call the
enrichment X is the log it's a
difference of the log of the fraction of
all reads so little n is the number of
reads in the IP big n is the total
number of reads in your P so this is the
log of the fraction of all reads that
map to this window in the IP this is the
fraction of all reads that map to this
window in the input sample the
difference i call the enrichment and
this model predict that this enrich if
there is no enrichment right so if this
just fluctuations then this X should
follow a Gaussian distribution but with
a variance that actually has two
components one component comes from this
multiplicative noise so that has some
somewhere in Sigma squared and then
there is basically variance that is
coming from the Poisson sampling that
goes like 1 over n plus 1 over m which
are the raw read counts alright and so
what we then do is we we fit a mixture
model where you say the all the windows
across the genome either come from this
background model or they come from some
uniform distribution where the
enrichment could be anything and then we
fit the three parameters right so mu
this shift Sigma and Rho to the data and
once we fit
to maximize the likelihood of the entire
chipset profiles we can now basically
for each window calculate the Z
statistic which is here which is given
here and so if there were no enriched
windows at all these sets statistics
should fall our standard normal all
right and if you now make plots of what
is the distribution of Z statistics that
you observe here in black compared to
the standard normal you see that indeed
the vast majority of the genome follows
this distribution and you can then quite
you know sort of Regulus rigorously pick
cut offs on the z-score so that your
total false discovery rate is let's say
ten percent I think this is actually
important because we've used this also
to see when we do not trust the orig
Peaks okay so when the experiments work
well you find that these distributions
fit very well and so you feel confident
that you know what an enriched region is
really enriched sometimes when something
goes wrong these black distributions
look crazy and you know that there's
probably a trouble and you shouldn't
really trust these and so in the
regulatory motif analysis of what we do
is we so in the past I've I've developed
various algorithms for doing motif
finding up initial especially taking
into account comparative genomic
information so we take peak regions we
find autologous regions in other genomes
we make alignments and then we run these
de novo motif finders so we get a
collection of the Nova motifs and we
combine that so we've collected a large
library of known motif so there's like
2,300 more fees from all these these
various resources and ended and then
what we do is we try to find a set of
complementary so non redundant motifs
that jointly observe the explain binding
peaks and we use the same enrichment
score that I showed you previously of
how likely is it to pull out the
sequences that you actually observed if
you assume that the probability of
pulling out the sequence is proportional
to the predicted number of binding sites
for this set of motifs
and yeah so for example for here so as
well for one example so for a tf2 from
from the encode data set right so we
find that the most predictive motif is
some sort of novel motif but then
actually you can add a number of motifs
from from this library that are
complementary to this and then jointly
these motifs better explain the binding
sites I will just focus on one thing
that really struck me to come back to
your oh ok good so thank you so I'll
just summarize and give you
acknowledgement so basically I told you
about this website web server that we
developed for automated ship six
analysis I encourage you to go there and
look at our results of miller full
encode data sets and i told you about
the dinucleotide waiting sir models for
taking or dependencies between positions
in by an exciting to count and this work
was done by cerrito midi and the main
work on was done by seven in burger and
lucas berg burger originally developed
this bayesian dinucleotide weight
handsome all all right so thank you very
much
you want first all right I to apply or
validate the 911 in vitro day coming
because we catch problematic so let's
look at the VMS them yes we have okay so
so what we've done is that we've taken
the motifs that we fitted on the ship
sank data both the weight matrix and the
dwt and then look for HT Selig's data
were the same two super factor was used
and you find that for the vast majority
of cases the dwt indeed does better than
the weight matrix model the reason I'm
not showing you this is because I don't
understand the HD selects data okay
there are so I know when people analyze
this they look for k-mers they take one
round stay you know so on so on so on I
understand you can do this but I'd like
to write down a model that says what's
the probability of the entire data set
all rounds how many times do I see each
sequence given that I assume it has a
certain total binding energy and that
model doesn't work okay there are lots
and lots of sequences that stick around
that shouldn't and so that's why I'm not
showing you yet because I don't feel
comfortable yet that I understand what's
going on in that data
it's a straightforward way to go further
than looking at cares including their
correlation because you said this
doesn't need to overfitting so good one
go further not sure I spent some time
trying to try to see if I can do a more
general Markov random field where I
don't have to constrain myself to trees
because especially for the sprouting
contact prediction problem that will be
great because I think we know the
context are not trees right but but you
can't get the nice factorization anymore
and and and so yes so you would get
these higher order terms that you would
have to integrate over and yeah so it's
not obvious to me how to do the factors
I mean we could talk about it but so I
don't know how to do it it's the simpler
times ah sorry
yep